une question à 63 dollars par mois est
ce que vous êtes satisfait de votre
fournisseur de services de
télécommunications protégez vous dévoile
son nouveau palmarès des meilleurs des
peas opérateurs pour nous dire comment
réduire notre facture aussi je sais que
ça va vous intéresser clément ça
marcherait avec nous pour nous en parler
bonjour alors vous vous êtes attaqués
pas un petit morceau qu'est ce qu'on
trouve dans le dossier ce mois ci mais
d'abord on a mené une vaste enquête
auprès de plus de 4300 répondant donc on
les a vraiment sondés sur leur
satisfaction par rapport à leurs
fournisseurs de télécommunications dans
le service à la clientèle que la qualité
de la connexion l'écrit offert aussi et
en complément on a aussi un article très
des meilleurs téléphones intelligents
sur un marché où il ya déjà des mecs
sont levés d'un salon à la télé dit
qu'ils sont les meilleures conditions
mais il ya plusieurs petits joueurs là
qui se classent bienvenue dans notre
palmarès qu des gros noms là comme
vidéotron cogeco ou rogers donc parmi
les meilleurs on retrouve iboxx teksavvy
et derry télécom déry telecom qui est
surtout actif au saguenay-lac-saint-jean
le rentier de charlevoix
on a aussi au magicjack deux compagnies
qui se spécialise dans la téléphonie
résidentielle par internet
donc il ya vraiment des très bas prix du
côté de la téléphonie pour des forfaits
cellulaires intéressant il ya koudou et
virgin qui s'en sort très bien aussi et
finalement seulement telus là parmi les
garnements grands noms le cclat savent
pas comment se fait-il que les tout
petits pas se défiler tous les tout
petits les plus petits les joints sont
semble être mieux s'en tirer dans en
termes de service ou même de coups il ya
beaucoup de plaintes au sujet des gros
joueurs vont d'abord les prix offerts le
qui sont souvent plus compétitif ensuite
le manque de clarté de transparence
lorsqu'on part de la facturation mais
aussi des hausses de tarifs le souben et
finalement
le sentiment que le service à la
clientèle et la plus tôt pour pousser la
vente de produits plutôt que vraiment
répondre à des questions ou aidez le à
régler des problèmes
bon ce qui est des fournisseurs même que
vous déconseiller complètement y est
belle qui arrive vraiment dernier de
notre palmarès beaucoup beaucoup
d'insatisfactions du côté de bell
sinon les gens hors des grands centres
urbains sont mal servis
parce que xplornet télébec de deux
fournisseurs régionaux arrive aussi dans
le bas de notre palmarès les jambes on
trouve d'abord que c'est très cher que
le service est pas à la hauteur et
souvent les gens se sentent un peu prise
en otage par ce qui est bien des
endroits où il ya seulement une option
disponible
je veux juste être est la même les plus
petits joueurs qui sont régionaux vous
les avez mentionné dans certains cas est
ce que est ce qu'on peut et est-ce que
c'est seulement dans ces régions là qui
sont disponibles où ils sont disponibles
partout mail chat chaque de chaque
fournisseur ces régions les horaires
pour vraiment s'informer là par rapport
à où envie on a quand même une dizaine
de recommandations donc est si vous
évitez quand même dans un milieu semi
urbain vous devriez avoir le plusieurs
choix parmi nos recommandations
qu'est-ce que vous recommandez justement
à ceux qui trouvent là qui sont complets
beaucoup trop cher pour la gamme de
services et mot d'ordre c'est vraiment
de négocier donc si vous êtes satisfait
de votre fournisseur ben ali quand même
voir ce que la compétition offre
servez vous de ces prix là comme levier
de négociation si vous n'êtes pas
satisfait de votre fournisseur bien le
regarder le du côté de ce qu'on
recommande puis profiter encore mène
pour faire jouer le le
les offres des compétiteurs sur notre
site internet
on offre gratuitement d'ailleurs deux
comparateur de forfaits pour les
forfaits internet pour les forfaits
cellulaires donc sont mis
continuellement à jour donc vous allez
pouvoir voir selon votre profil ou les
cris sont les plus intéressants puis
vous servez de cette information-là au
besoin pour négocier bon puis souvent
ces forfaits notamment cellule à vienne
avec une offre d'appareils aussi dont
klaus aussi vous avez il ya des usagers
qui disent lequel des téléphones ils ont
préféré
oui mais en fait le test de téléphone
c'est vraiment un test en laboratoire à
bord at war en 9 79 appareils sont mis
au banc d'essai et puis on a une
vingtaine de recommandations là dans le
magasin à chaque fois que vous vous
dites vous mais produit toujours des
jeunes et vous le test sur dow prend des
vérifications
oui mais c'était ce qu'on fait en
collaboration avec beaucoup de magazines
à travers le monde donc on met toutes
nos ressources en commun et puis le test
est fait en europe et puis on teste
vraiment le des centaines de
caractéristiques pour trouver les
meilleurs appareils autres
le temps est bon si vous voulez si vous
magasinez un forfait puis un téléphone
c'est le temps d'acheter protégez vous
merci beaucoup d'études voit reprocher